في ناس اللي يسمونهم
الناس اللي يسافرون عشان بس يقول انا
سافرت عدد معين يدخل بلد كم ساعه عشان
يقول انا والله سافرت الرقم الفعلي
بالنهايه طيب هذا البلد ولا شيء حتى اذكر
قبلت وحده هنا كانت السعوديه اول ما
الفيزا يعني ما صدقت من السعوديه الجو
والله العظيم ما جلست يوم في الرياض بعدين
راحت ونزل السوشيال ميديا خلاص نزلت
السعوديه السعوديه كامله تشوف الخريطه
تقول زرت السعوديه وهي في الرياض مجلسه
يوم حتى
[موسيقى]
يوسف ستيس
مؤثر في مجال السفر والسياحه
في السوشيال ميديا صار لي تقريبا اكثر من
13 سنه الحين لكن بالسفر زمان اكثر من
عشرين سنه ما احب كلمه رحاله ابدا مشكله
رحاله الناس فهمتها بطريقه
غلط لانه الناس تعتقد دائما تقول رحالي
جبالهم على طول واحد شنطته على ظهره
ويتمشى ويركب مع ناس وحياه يعني مبهدله
خلينا نقول سائح او سواح سواح ان حاطه في
البايو حقي لانه هذه نقطه ثانيه وانا بوصل
الناس فكره انه انا ترى سائح ماني لانه
السفر مجال السفر ما في شخص تقول هذا خبير
حتى لو انه مثلا
مشاكل او اخطاء او اشياء فانا انسان عادي
يعني ماني خبير وكل شيء عندي عارفه في
مجال السفر وفي كل مكان في العالم
[موسيقى]
اشياء بسيطه يعني سافرت مع ناس قبل كنت
يعني اصدقائي وكذا
ما قلت يعني علاقتنا مستمره لكن السفر
خربت الشخص اللي معي بيروح ينام الحين
لازم نروح او هذا المطعم الفلاني لا وهذا
الشخص اليوم مال خلق يسوي كذا لا خويك
اللي انت تشوفه هنا
وخلاص لكن في السفر معاك 24 ساعه فبتمرون
بكل المواقف
تعصبون بعض وتتهاوشون تتفقون تضحكون عشان
كذا اقول لك انه في ناس اللي احبهم واللي
مره والناس اللي يقول لا ما اسافر مع بعض
لانه بتطلع بلاوي انا ما بعرفها عنك وانت
ما تبي تعرفها عني فخلينا بعيدين
بدايه سفراتي كنت انسان دقيق واخطط ولازم
اعرف كل شيء في المكان اللي اسافر وهذا
كان قبل اكثر من عشر سنين
وصلت مرحله انه انا معهد استمتع بها
بالتخطيط او حتى بالسفره اذا كانت مخططه
وقفت من من تقريبا
سبع ثمان سنوات وقفت تخطيط اروح العب معها
اكبر واكبر وافضل
لكن عيبها طبعا انها بتكون مكلفه اكثر بس
انه اعرف مثلا بروح لهذه المنطقه يلا بس
لقيت شي في الطريق وقف فيه رحت هناك ما
عجبتني بكره غير انه مرن جدا صرت في موضوع
السفر وهذا شي يعني
خلاني استمتع بالسفر بشكل اكثر واشوف
اشياء جديده
فعلا اجلس في المكان اللي انا فعلا عاجبني
مو عشان والله لا انا مرتب انا صفاتي كانت
سياحه
ما بيخليها انه مهمه عمل اتكلم مع صفات
انه تروح عندك جدول لازم تمشي على هذا
الجدول تقعد حتى لو البلد ما عجبك لازم
ثلاث اربع ايام هذه ما صارت سفره يعني
تحتاج اجازه
[موسيقى]
عقبه زمنيه من السبعينات ما في انترنت حتى
لو حصلت انترنت وزي مثلا المودم حاطينه في
الحديقه الفلانيه الحديقه بس هذه اللي
فيها الانترنت عشان تشبك على الانترنت هذا
لازم تروح المكتب وتقدم تجيب جوازك وتعبي
ابلكيشن وتدفع عشان بس تاخذ بطاقه انترنت
لمده ساعه والانترنت سيء جدا لدرجه انه
حتى محادثه الواتساب ما تطلع يعني تخيل
الموقف اللي كسر خاطري ولد صغير يعني
[موسيقى]
انا سمعت كان يتكلم انجليزي
يقول انا سمعت انه انتم
معك جوالك في انترنت طول الوقت سمع قلت له
طيب انتم الحين كيف انتم بتطلع مع اخوياك
في هذا الوقت كيف فقال لي يوم عندهم
بطاقات
الانترنت هادئ اقولك عنها بس بعد بيانات
معين خليها على اطول مده وش يسوي يروح
المكان هذا حق الانترنت ويدخل يروح على
الايميل يرسل
لصاحبه شوفوا شوفوا التعقيد انه بوقت
الثاني مكان الفلاني كده اذا هذاك متى ما
فتح يمكن يفتحها قبل البتاع قبل ما تدري
اغلب الشرطه
فيروحون تبينا التليفون او حتى زي السوبر
ماركت او البقاله الصغيره يعطيه فلوس
يستخدم التليفون حقه
سيء
والناس كلها تلقاها مثلا بيوتهم طالعين
عند عتبه الباب
سولفون الجيران مع بعض يعني
في اي بلد يعني
[موسيقى]
اعتقد
زين لابسه في النمسا
لا لانه ما كان فيها شيء مختلف عن باقي
البحيرات في سويسرا والنمسا طبيعه سويسرا
والنمسا معروفه من اجمل الاماكن الطبيعيه
في العالم
فما كان فيها اي اضافه او شيء مختلف عن
باقي البحيرات بالاضافه لانها كانت زحمه
الاسعار تكون فيها مرتفعه وما تلقى مكان
سكن وتحس البلد شوي في فوضى مع الزحمه
يعني بس صغيره جدا يعني بالنهايه ما في
شيء مختلف تطلع اي بحيره ثانيه جنبها نفس
الشيء وين ما تروح يعني مكان جميل طبيعي
يعني ترى هذا برضو نقطه مهمه جدا عامل
الانبهار بعد كثره السفر هذا تقريبا يصير
نادر جدا انه يصير لك من فتره لفتره بس او
تقول اه والله هذا انا انبحرت بهذا المكان
فلما تنبه اوكي يعني حصل شيء جديد زي
مختلف
قبل ما اروح وانا في الرياض كلمتني شركه
جوالات قالوا بنعطيك جوال
اعلان وتصور فيه وكذا اوكي طيب اوكي انا
عندي رحله
فخلوني اخذ الجوال معاي هذا الجديد عشان
اصور فيه وانا مسافر بالعكس يكون في تاثير
اكبر معاي انا جوالي العادي وهذا جوال
جديد
وانا في الطياره
اوكي خليني الحين اجرب الجوال يعني تعرف
الجوال جدا ما اعرف استخدمه شركه ثانيه
غير جوالي ففتحته في الطياره طلعت من
كرتونه
ما في بطاريه قلت اوكي خليني اشحنه في
الطياره تحت هذا زي المكان حق الشحن
وحطيته في الشاحن
نمت لين وصلت لما وصلت في رحله ترانزيت
فتره زيت كان عندي قليل واحنا وصلنا
متاخرين فلازم بسرعه لازم الطياره عشان
الحق الطياره الثانيه فعلى طول خدت اغراضي
طلعت ركبت الطياره الثانيه لما وصلت
تحت واشوف الكرتون انا الكرتون جوال حطيته
في الشنطه يشحن
يا ساتر نسيته في الطياره عموما اول يوم
طلعنا الحين معي جوالي اول يوم طلعنا مكان
سياحي كذا يطيح الجوال وينفتح نصين اول
مره بحياتي جوالي ينكسر لهالدرجه يعني مو
شيء يتصلح انكسر تماما
نمت صحيت بكره صحيت ما ادري الوقت الساعه
كم انا ما كان معي ساعه وما عندي جوال
والغرفه اللي انا ما كان فيها ساعه بتخيل
[ضحك]
اعتقد في الصين في كوبا
شوف تركيا ما عندي مشكله اني اروح لهنا كل
ما اشوفها
تختلف لانه هي جنب اليونان وحتى انا كنت
في اليونان في جزيره كوست عن بودروم اقل
من نصف ساعه فهي نفس الطبيعه ونفس الشيء
الاكل لذيذ وطبيعه وكل شيء لكن بالنهايه
لو انت في اجمل مكان في الدنيا وشخص
جمال المكان هذا اصلا خلاص بيكره المكان
شكرا اللي فيه وتمشي انا دائما اقول للناس
او الشعب هم اهم شيء او اهم سبب يخلي
الناس تحب البلد او ما تحب البلد ما هو
موضوع طبيعه ما هو موضوع جو ما هو موضوع
اكل طبعا هذه كلها عناصر تضيف انا اشوف
الشعب رقم واحد
في بالي في اندونيسيا اللي هو عندهم يوم
الصمت اعتقادي ان الارواح الشريره تجي على
كل البلد
اي احد طالع
يمشي في الشارع او مشغل النور او تكلم صوت
عالي او يمارس اي نشاط طبيعي يومي راح
تتلبسوا هذه الارواح اليوم الصمت عندهم
يقفلون كل شيء كل المطاعم المطار يقفل
المطاعم
الانشطه كل شيء يعني كانه تصير مدينه
اشباح فعلا تطلع بالشارع ما في احد ولا
تقدر تطلع للشارع ممنوع حتى لو انت سائح
حتى لو انت جالس في الفندق ما تطلع من
غرفتك لو تبي تطلب اكل تطلب قبل تخليه
عندك لانه اصلا ما في حد يشتغل الموظفين
كلهم يروحون ما تقدر تشغل نور او نار حتى
على الشاطئ او حتى في اي مكان عشان كذا
يسموني يوم الصوت ما تتكلم حد يتكلم بعدين
اليوم اللي بعده يكون احتفال كبير احتفال
انه خلاص راحت الارواح الشريره عن بلدنا
الحين احنا ما صارت فينا لانه احنا
التزمنا بالصمت والهدوء فكان يعني شيء
غريب او اعتقاد غريب
[موسيقى]
فوصلت كان واحد ينتظرني
مندي واسمي مكتوب في اللوحه
اوكي انا معك رحت
بحالي طبعا هو الساعه 2:00 في الليل وطني
انا اول مره ازور تنزانيا واول مره هذا
اول شخص اشوفه يعني ونمشي هدوء وظلام
رايحين في وسط الطريق هو حاب يتاكد يعني
بعد ما طلعنا المطار انه الشخص اللي معه
هو نفس الشخص اللي اتاكد فيقول هو يسوق
كذا يقرا يوسف مستر يوسف
[موسيقى]
الله يستر يعني في احد من قبل نفس الاسم
سوي لي مشكله ولا شيء فنزل من السواق وجاء
عندي ويفتح الباب انا كنت مستعد على ضرب
على طول الموضوع قلت اختطاف
وما في ايه يعرفها ولا دعاء الا ويقوله
ويتبرك فيني
ما كنت متوقع هذا يعني الشيء يصير ابدا
اخر شيء
هو باعتقاده لانه مسلم خلاص مرتبط عنده في
مكه فعلى اساسا انا جاي من مكه
حلم حياته انه يروح مكه كنت اقول له يعني
اوكي يعني
من مكه يعني
انا من السعوديه بس انا من الرياض
تمام الله يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك
وشكرا لكم يعطيكم العافيه ما قصرتو معليش
والله لو تكلمت كثير وتطورناها
[موسيقى]